Mariya is always a little embarrassed to admit how much she loved high school. But the truth is she really loved it. This is outside Houston. She had friends. Liked her classes and Friday night football and backyard pool parties. She was editor-in-chief of the school paper. Felt a lot of freedom.
Mariya对于自己高中时期有多么热爱那段时光总是感到有些尴尬，但事实是，她确实非常喜欢。那是在休斯顿郊外。她有朋友，喜欢上课、周五晚上的橄榄球赛和后院的泳池派对。她是校报的主编，感觉非常自由。
And then this disquieting thing happened during her senior year, when everybody was applying to colleges. When you apply to a state school in Texas, Mariya explained to me, Texas has their own Common App.
后来，在她高三那年，也就是大家都在申请大学的时候，发生了一件令人不安的事。Mariya向我解释说，当你申请德克萨斯州的公立学校时，德州有他们自己的一套通用申请表。
And it's only for people applying to a public university in Texas. But there were four different essay prompts. And one of those was Essay B.
这套表格只针对申请德州公立大学的学生。但里面有四个不同的作文题目，其中一个是“作文B”。
Essay topic B, like A, B, C, D.
作文题目B，就像A、B、C、D那样。
Do you want me to read it?
你想让我读一下吗？
Sure.
当然。
OK. "Many students expand their view of the world during their time in college. Such growth often results from encounters between students who have lived different cultural, economic, or academic experiences. With your future growth in mind, describe a potential classmate that you believe you could learn from, either within or outside a formal classroom environment.
好的。“许多学生在大学期间会拓宽他们的世界观。这种成长往往源于有着不同文化、经济或学术背景的学生之间的接触。考虑到你未来的成长，请描述一位你认为能从中学习的潜在同学，无论是在正式课堂内外。”
Wait, wait. So they're asking a potential classmate. In other words, make up a classmate who you have not met.
等等，等等。所以他们要求写的是一位“潜在的同学”。换句话说，虚构一个你还没见过的同学。
Yeah. Imagine a hypothetical person who is different from you in some way.
对。想象一个在某些方面与你不同的人。
Mariya never actually answered Essay Topic B because she wanted to go to college out of state and she applied early admission. But there were a few days in her English class during that year where the rest of the class that was applying to state schools wrote and worked on their college essays. Because Mariya didn't need to write any essays to get into Texas schools, the teacher asked her to help edit them. Mariya ran the school paper, so she had some skills.
Mariya其实从没回答过作文题目B，因为她想去外州的大学，而且她申请了提前录取。但在那一年里，她的英语课上有几天时间，班里其他申请州立学校的同学都在写和修改他们的大学申请作文。因为Mariya不需要写这些申请德州学校的作文，老师就让她帮忙修改。Mariya经营着校报，所以她有一些文笔技巧。
So I was sitting in this class and I was reading all of these essays about a future hypothetical person that helps them grow. And they didn't actually write about a future hypothetical person. They all wrote about me.
所以我当时坐在教室里，读着所有这些关于未来虚构人物如何帮助他们成长的作文。但他们实际上写的根本不是什么未来的虚构人物。他们写得全都是我。
They all wrote about you?
他们写的全都是你？
Yeah.
是的。
Wait. They were writing about you as if they hadn't met you and someday might meet someone like you?
等等。他们写你的时候，就好像他们还没见过你，但以后可能会遇到像你这样的人？
Yeah, exactly.
对，没错。
And then they explained all the important lessons they were going to learn from future imaginary you?
然后他们解释了所有他们将从未来的虚构的你身上学到的重要课程？
Yes. But before they did that, they had to describe me. And so I was reading these sentences about myself.
是的。但在写这些之前，他们必须描述我。所以我一直在读这些关于我自己的句子。
Two key facts all of her classmates dwelled upon. Mariya is from Pakistan, and she's Muslim, at a high school that was mostly white and not Muslim.
所有同学在文章中反复强调了两个关键事实：Mariya来自巴基斯坦，而且她是穆斯林，而这是一所大多数学生是白人且非穆斯林的高中。
In a lot of the classes, I was the only nonwhite person. And a lot of times, outside of school, I would go to parties or social gatherings and I would be the only nonwhite person there.
在很多课上，我是唯一的非白人。而且很多时候，在校外，我会去参加聚会或社交场合，我也是那里唯一的非白人。
So I'm picturing you have a stack of a couple dozen essays and you're going through them and everyone is talking about you?
所以我能想象，你面前有一叠几十份作文，你在翻阅它们，每个人都在谈论你？
I mean, there were some people who did not write about me. They did actually come up with a hypothetical future person and wrote about those people, offensively. There was one in particular in which the guy wrote about his roommate who had super, super greasy hair and smelled like sandalwood.
我是说，确实有一些人没有写我。他们真的想出了一个虚构的未来人物，并且写了关于那些人的内容，带有歧视色彩。其中特别有一个人，他写的是他的室友，那个人头发非常、非常油腻，身上还有檀香味。
What does that mean? What is that referring to?
那是什么意思？那是暗示什么吗？
Yeah. He was like some Indian kid who managed to find common ground. I think the common ground was like video games. I'm not kidding.
对。他大概是个印度小孩，他们找到了共同点。我想那个共同点是电子游戏之类的。我没开玩笑。
Mariya brought to the studio a couple of the essays written about her by her high school friends, including one written by one of her best friends at the time, Jenna, who's still one of her best friends. Mariya was a bridesmaid at her wedding. All of Mariya's winter stuff is stored in Jenna's garage right now. Here's Jenna's Essay B.
Mariya带到了演播室几篇她高中朋友写给她的作文，其中一篇出自她当时最好的朋友Jenna之手，她现在仍然是Mariya最好的朋友之一。Mariya曾是她婚礼的伴娘。Mariya所有的冬装现在都存放在Jenna的车库里。这是Jenna的“作文B”。
OK. I'll just start.
好的，我开始了。
"As-salamu alaykum. Hello. It's a customary Islamic greeting and so much fun to pronounce."
“As-salamu alaykum（愿你平安）。你好。这是一种习惯性的伊斯兰问候语，发音非常有趣。”
That's the opener?
那是开场白？
Yes.
是的。
OK.
好吧。
"Almost every evening when my cell phone rings, I'll see Mari's name on the caller ID, flip open the phone, and hastily cry, as-salamu alaykum." And this is a real person writing about me. I'm Mari. And I can guarantee that I don't think that anyone who is white has ever answered the phone and said "as-salamu alaykum" to me. And then she explains. "I'm not Muslim. For that matter, I'm also not Middle Eastern or South Asian. And I certainly can't speak the tongue of those regions."
“几乎每天晚上当我的手机响起，看到Mari的名字出现在来电显示上，我都会滑开手机，急切地喊道：As-salamu alaykum。”这是一个真实的人在写关于我的事。我是Mari。我可以保证，我不认为任何白人在接我电话时会对我说“As-salamu alaykum”。然后她解释道：“我不是穆斯林。再说，我也不是中东人或南亚人。我当然也不会说那些地区的语言。”
Jenna then describes how someday she's going to meet this fictional Mari at college on the first day of Intro to Psychology in the middle of a sea of kids who were wearing T-shirts.
Jenna接着描述了她将来如何在大学心理学导论课的第一天，在穿着T恤的人海中遇见这个虚构的Mari。
"My eye caught the gorgeous, intricate beading of a handmade sari. At the time, I hadn't the faintest idea what a sari was. I was merely awestruck by someone who would willingly wear such a bold outfit."
“我的目光捕捉到了手工纱丽上华丽、精致的珠饰。当时，我对于纱丽是什么完全没有概念。我只是对那个愿意穿得如此大胆的人感到敬畏。”
And did you wear a sari all the time?
那你经常穿纱丽吗？
No. I have worn a sari-- I'm almost 30, and I've worn a sari maybe twice in my life. And then she goes on. She says, "Her dark, daring South Asian eyes met mine, and she smiled."
不。我快30岁了，这辈子可能也就穿过两次纱丽。然后她继续写道：“她那双深邃、大胆的南亚眼睛迎向了我，她微笑着。”
"Her dark, daring South Asian eyes"?
“她那双深邃、大胆的南亚眼睛”？
Yep. Yep. Followed by, "She was not the typical Indian woman I had seen in National Geographic."
是的，没错。接着是：“她不是我在《国家地理》里看到的那种典型的印度女性。”
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
I don't know. I'm wearing a sari.
我不知道。我当时正穿着纱丽呢。
Was it weird that suddenly you realized that they're seeing you as their exotic friend?
当你意识到他们把你视为他们的“异域风情”朋友时，有没有觉得很奇怪？
Yeah, it was super weird. I didn't know that they saw me that way until I read about it in these essays.
对，这超级奇怪。在读到这些作文之前，我根本不知道他们是这样看我的。
Because how did you see yourself?
因为你是怎么看待自己的呢？
I saw myself as having fully fit in into this super white high school.
我觉得自己完全融入了这所超级白人的高中。
This, in fact, had been a determined, calculated, five-year campaign on Mariya's part, starting when she was 12 years old and her family moved from Pakistan. She carried around a little notebook, where she'd record important details, like at her friend's house, the family drank milk with dinner. Mariya wrote in the notebook, "Americans drink milk with dinner," then tried to get her parents to serve it. To get rid of her Pakistani accent, she embarked on a project that took hours every day after middle school. On the VCR in the family game room, she'd record her favorite TV show, Lizzie McGuire.
事实上，这是Mariya从12岁那年随家人从巴基斯坦搬来后，进行的一场坚定、经过计算的五年计划。她随身带着一个小笔记本，记录重要细节，比如在朋友家，这家人晚饭时喝牛奶。Mariya在笔记本上写道：“美国人晚饭喝牛奶”，然后试着让父母也这样准备。为了摆脱巴基斯坦口音，她开始了每天放学后花几小时的项目。在家里游戏室的录像机上，她会录下她最喜欢的电视节目《莉琪的异想世界》（Lizzie McGuire）。
And then play back Hilary Duff speaking. And then I would repeat what she had said and record it.
然后播放Hilary Duff说话的声音，我就会重复她说过的话并录下来。
On the family computer, using Windows Media Player.
在家里电脑上，使用Windows Media Player。
And then play them simultaneously, hear the differences, and then fix my accent. So I basically copied Hilary Duff's accent. So even now, I sound a lot like a 13-year-old Hilary Duff.
然后同步播放它们，听出差别，再修正我的口音。所以我基本复制了Hilary Duff的口音。所以即使现在，我听起来还很像13岁的Hilary Duff。
Now, as an adult, I'm able to look back at all those things that I did to be more American and say I wasn't really trying to be more American. I was trying to be more white. And then all of a sudden, I was confronted with these essays, and they were all like, and you're not!
现在，作为一个成年人，我能够回顾我所做的所有为了让自己更美国化的事情，并说我当时并不是真的想变得更美国化。我是想变得更白人化。然后突然之间，我面对这些作文，它们都在说：你根本不是！
Yeah. That is a really sobering moment, huh?
对。那真是一个令人清醒的时刻，不是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. Because you have this project you've been working on for years. You think you're killing it. You're doing such an amazing job. You feel so close to these people, like you're totally integrated. Then you learn, like--
没错。因为你有一个坚持了这么多年的项目。你以为你做得非常好。你感觉与这些人如此亲近，就像你完全融入了一样。然后你发现……
Yeah. It was not fun. And it was not pleasant. And I was in this classroom setting, and my friends were willingly giving me their essays to read, and everyone around me was acting as though it was this giant compliment.
是啊。这真的一点也不好玩。一点也不愉快。我当时坐在那个教室里，我的朋友们自愿把她们的作文给我读，周围每个人表现得好像这是一种巨大的赞美。
Wait. Why was it a compliment?
等等。为什么这是一种赞美？
Because they'd all written about me, like how great that I was immortalized in all of these college applications.
因为她们全都写了我，好像我被永载入这些大学申请书是一件多么伟大的事一样。
I know. But it's like they're saying, oh, you're our cute little mascot.
我知道。但这就像是她们在说，哦，你是我们可爱的吉祥物。
Yeah. It's a little bit like that. Yeah. Like, my Pakistani friend Mariya. And if you had asked me to describe my best friends, it's not like I would've been like, yeah, my friend Katie, who's a white Southern Baptist from Texas. Those are not identifiers I would have used. I would have just said, my friend Katie.
对，有点像那样。就像“我的巴基斯坦朋友Mariya”。如果你让我描述我最好的朋友，我才不会说“我的朋友Katie，一位来自德州的白人浸信会教徒”。这些根本不是我会用的标签。我会直接说“我的朋友Katie”。
Mariya is the first to say her friends were just trying to give the answer that Essay Topic B seemed to be asking for. It is a really weird essay prompt. It's basically telling 17-year-olds to imagine a stereotype of somebody who's different from them and then explain how they would learn the right lessons from this stereotyped person. The kids were basically writing what they think some admissions office wants to hear.
Mariya首先表示，她的朋友只是试图给出“作文题目B”似乎想要得到的答案。这确实是一个非常奇怪的题目。它本质上是在告诉17岁的孩子去想象一个与他们不同的人的刻板印象，然后解释他们将如何从这个被刻板印象化的人身上学到正确的道理。孩子们只是在写他们认为招生办想听的内容。
And of everything in all these essays, there was one section of one essay that got to Mariya the most. It was in the Essay B that her best friend Jenna wrote. Jenna has a scene in her essay where she pictures someday studying for a psychology final with this supposedly fictional girl, Mari, that she imagines meeting at college and befriending.
在所有这些作文中，有一部分让Mariya最介意。那就在她最好的朋友Jenna写的“作文B”里。Jenna在作文中有一个场景，设想将来在大学里复习心理学期末考时，和这个所谓的虚构女孩Mari一起，也就是她想象中在大学遇见并交好的朋友。
This moment is not a hypothetical. It's not a fake moment. It's an actual thing that happened between us.
这一刻并非假设。这不是虚假的时刻。这是发生在我们之间的真实事情。
OK. Let's hear.
好的，让我们听听。
So she describes herself. "I'm sitting cross-legged in my favorite gray sweats on my extra-long twin, scattered with a frightening number of psych notes. My faithful study buddy, Mari, leans against the bed, her knees pulled close to her chest, a mug of chai between her hands." I would not have been drinking chai.
她描述她自己：“我穿着我最喜欢的灰色运动服，盘腿坐在我的超长单人床上，上面散落着数量惊人的心理学笔记。我忠实的研究搭档Mari倚靠在床边，膝盖紧贴着胸口，手里捧着一杯印度拉茶（chai）。”我根本不会喝茶。
OK. What would you have been drinking?
好吧。那你当时会喝什么？
Coffee. And it would have been like a basic white girl, like Frappuccino pumpkin spice drink, too.
咖啡。而且会是那种肤浅的白人女孩喝的南瓜香料星冰乐之类的东西。
OK.
好吧。
"I'm flipping through the pages of my textbook when I run across a striking quote from the social psych chapter."
“当我正在翻看教科书时，我看到了社会心理学章节中一段引人注目的引用。”
The essay goes on to quote from the textbook, which says that the DNA that all humans share is mostly alike. And then when people are different races or ethnicities, the difference is less than 0.2% of their DNA. Here's Mariya reading more of Jenna's essay.
作文接下来引用了教科书的内容，说人类共享的DNA大部分是相似的。而当人们属于不同种族或民族时，差异不到他们DNA的0.2%。这是Mariya在读Jenna作文的更多内容。
"I read the stats aloud to Mari, then I excitedly spilled the thoughts running through my head. 'That makes so much sense. So much sense. You know, I've heard we all smile in the same language, but it goes so far beyond that, and I never realized it was possible until I met you, Mari. I had no idea I could connect with someone so completely opposite of me on such a deep level. We can read each other's looks. And no wonder. There's only a 0.2% difference between us.'"
“我大声把数据读给Mari听，然后兴奋地倾诉我脑海中闪过的想法：‘那太有道理了。真的太有道理了。你知道吗，我听说我们所有人都是用同一种语言微笑，但这不仅仅是这样，直到遇见你，Mari，我才意识到这是可能的。我从没想过我能与一个与我完全相反的人在如此深的层面上产生共鸣。我们可以解读对方的神情。难怪，我们之间只有0.2%的差异。’”
And this like killed me, reading this. It kills me now because it's like, I didn't need science to tell us that we were the same, and she did. And she was supposed to be my best friend. And it wasn't until she read a quote in a social psych chapter that she realized that the genetic differences between us was so slim that it made sense that we could be friends.
读到这里，我真是心如刀绞。我现在读起来也很难过，因为这就像是，我不需要科学来告诉我们我们是一样的，但她需要。而且她本应该是我最好的朋友。直到读了社会心理学章节里的一段引言，她才意识到我们之间的基因差异是如此之小，以至于我们成为朋友才合理。
They didn't talk about it. Mariya didn't know how. She was in this situation where their teacher and everybody else acted like this was normal, what they were all writing in their essays, and it was hard for her at the time to put her finger on what her problem with it was.
她们没谈过这个。Mariya不知道该怎么谈。她当时处于那种境地，老师和每个人都表现得这很正常，大家作文里写的都是这些，而且她当时很难说清自己对这些问题到底有什么不满。
I will just say that for 10 years or something like that, I carried this moment in writing along with me and I would reflect back upon it, about the fact that my best friend had to have science prove to her that we were similar enough to be able to be friends.
我只能说，大概十年来，我一直带着这篇文字，反复反思这个事实：我最好的朋友居然需要科学向她证明我们足够相似，以至于能够成为朋友。
Just this week, Mariya finally discussed all this with Jenna. She asked Jenna to go back and read her old high school Essay Topic B and then go into a studio to talk about it.
就在这一周，Mariya终于和Jenna讨论了这一切。她请Jenna回去读她高中时的“作文题目B”，然后走进演播室聊了聊。
And Jenna felt really bad about it. Here she is.
Jenna为此感到非常抱歉。她就在这儿。
I got this out to read it and I was like, womp-womp, it's going to be just something that I wrote when I was 17. And then I was like, oh, I get it. I get why this hurt. Yeah. It was hard for me to read.
我拿出来读的时候，心想：糟了，这肯定就是我17岁时写的垃圾。然后我就想，噢，我明白了。我明白了为什么这会伤人。是的。读起来真让我难受。
The parts that were especially hard for her to read were the fact that she made up that I wore saris, that she used my real name, the National Geographic bit. That was especially horrifying to her.
让她读起来特别难受的部分是，她编造了我穿纱丽的事，她用了我的真实姓名，《国家地理》那一段。那对她来说特别令人惊悚。
And did you guys talk about the DNA statistic?
那你们谈到那个DNA统计数据了吗？
Yeah. I told her that it made me feel like she needed science to validate our friendship.
谈了。我告诉她，那让我觉得她需要科学来验证我们的友谊。
I never intended that. I don't know why I used the word opposite so many times in this essay.
我从未那样想过。我不知道为什么我在作文里用了那么多次“相反”这个词。
Maybe because the prompt asked you to.
也许是因为题目要求你这样写。
Yeah. Yeah, maybe so. I don't think about you-- like, I never, never have. Even when I wrote this, I didn't think of you as someone who was opposite.
对。是的，也许吧。我不认为你……我从来、从来没有那样想过。即使在我写这篇作文的时候，我也没有把你当作一个完全相反的人。
Jenna said that in the essay, she was trying to say that the DNA science just confirmed something she already knew from our friendship.
Jenna说，在作文里，她只是想表达DNA科学证实了她在我们友谊中已经知道的事实。
It honestly did. Whether I express it well in the essay or not, it just clicked. I was like, yeah, of course. This is my experience. We're the same, and we can still relate in every way imaginable.
说实话确实如此。无论我是否在作文中表达得好，它就是一种直觉。我当时想：对，当然。这就是我的经历。我们是一样的，而且我们仍然可以在任何可以想象的层面上产生共鸣。
During the conversation, there was one moment where Jenna asked me something.
在对话中，有一个时刻Jenna问了我一件事。
Did you literally think that this is how I saw you?
你真的以为我就是这样看你的吗？
After the essay, a little bit, yes. There was a brief, two-year period in which I did.
在作文之后，有一点，是的。有那么短暂的两年时间，我是这么想的。
That's not very brief.
那可不算短暂。
But now I don't.
但现在我不再这么想了。
A version of Essay Topic B is still on the website with the Texas Common App, but instead of asking you to imagine a person who you're going to meet in college someday who's going to change you in some way, it asks you about somebody who you've already met whose, quote, "experiences and/or beliefs differ from yours." The old Essay B went further than that, of course. It asked how somebody from a different culture or economic background would benefit a student's, quote, "future growth," which, Mariya points out, seems to assume something about the applicant.
“作文题目B”的一个版本仍然在德州通用申请表的网站上，但它不再要求你想象一个将来在大学里遇见并会以某种方式改变你的人，而是问你关于一个你已经遇见过的、“其经历和/或信仰与你不同”的人。旧的作文B当然走得更远。它询问一个来自不同文化或经济背景的人如何使学生的“未来成长”受益，Mariya指出，这似乎对申请者做出了一种预设。
Even when I was in high school and I was reading this prompt, I remember being very aware of the fact that that question was not meant for me. Every time I read it, I had to think like, who on Earth am I going to write about? Who is different from me? I just can't get around the idea that the question is only for white people.
即使我在读高中并读到这个题目时，我就很清楚那个问题不是为我设计的。每次读它，我都得想：我到底该写谁？谁与我不同？我始终无法摆脱这个念头：这个问题只针对白人。
It says, "With your future growth in mind, describe a potential classmate that you believe you could learn from." When it's saying, "Your future growth in mind," who is the "your" in that context? In my opinion, it's white people. Who else needs to learn and grow from people different from them? It's like the prompt is saying that college is for white people and everyone else is here for the benefit of white people.
上面写着：“考虑到你未来的成长，描述一位你认为能从中学习的潜在同学。”当它说“考虑到你未来的成长”时，这个语境下的“你”是谁？在我看来，是白人。还有谁需要向与自己不同的人学习和成长？这题目简直是在说大学是给白人上的，而其他人在这里都是为了白人的利益。
There are different ways to talk about why it's important to have a mix of people in a school together. Way back in the 1950s, when the Supreme Court decision mandated school desegregation, the language used was that this is the fair and democratic thing to do. It was just right for everybody to be treated the same. But in the years since then, another idea has come forward that you run into all the time in schools and in lots of other settings, that diversity is important because it's good for the majority. It's good for white people. It's not always said that way flat out. Often, it's kind of implicit, like in Essay Topic B.
有很多种方式来讨论为什么在一个学校里拥有多元化的人群很重要。早在20世纪50年代，当最高法院裁决强制学校废除种族隔离时，使用的语言是：这是公平且民主的做法。对待每个人一视同仁才是对的。但在此后的几年里，另一个观点开始浮现，你在学校和许多其他场合经常会遇到：多元化很重要，因为它对多数群体有好处。它对白人有好处。这并不总是被直接说出来。通常，这是一种隐含的意思，就像在“作文题目B”中那样。
Today on our program, we have a story of a program from back in the 1960s that ran all across the South. It was started for a bunch of reasons, but the primary one was this one-- to change the thinking of white people. Today on our show, we hear how that played out over decades in real life.
今天在我们的节目中，有一个来自20世纪60年代、在整个南方运作的项目故事。它发起的初衷有很多，但最主要的是这一个——改变白人的想法。今天在节目中，我们听听这在现实生活中几十年来是如何演变的。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act 1, How to Win Friends and Influence White People.
第一幕，如何赢得朋友并影响白人。
OK. So 35 years before Mariya had that experience in her high school, some Black kids were drafted into a project created by a small group called The Stouffer Foundation. They would be the children whose presence in the lives of white kids would impart valuable lessons to the white kids. And before they got to do that, they had to go through an admissions interview.
好的。那么在Mariya经历那件事的35年前，一些黑人孩子被选入了一个由名为Stouffer基金会的小团体创建的项目。他们将成为那些生命中出现并给白人孩子传授宝贵经验的黑人孩子。在他们开始履行职责之前，他们必须通过一次招生面试。
Testing, testing. One, two, three.
试音，试音。一，二，三。
Some of these were recorded. This is a 14-year-old named Doug. And the person that he's being interviewed by was kind of a random semi-celebrity back then, a British stage actress named Rosemary Harris. She's in film sometimes, too. You may have seen her decades later playing Aunt May in Spider-Man. Anyway, in this interview, Rosemary and Doug talk about his grades. He's mostly getting As and Bs, one C. They talk about his science fair project, what he thinks makes a good teacher.
其中一些被录音了。这是一个叫Doug的14岁男孩。面试他的人在当时是一位半知名的名人，一位英国舞台剧女演员，名叫Rosemary Harris。她有时也演电影。几十年前你可能见过她在《蜘蛛侠》里扮演梅婶。总之，在这次面试中，Rosemary和Doug聊了他的成绩。他大多数是A和B，得了一个C。他们聊了他的科学博览会项目，以及他认为什么样的老师是好老师。
Our French teacher, he's a good teacher, but he just can't keep a quiet class. Most of the class is quiet until they get in French.
我们的法语老师，他是个好老师，但他就是没法让班里安静下来。班里大部分时间都很安静，直到他们进了法语课。
They don't like French.
他们不喜欢法语。
Well, his classes are kind of boring.
嗯，他的课有点无聊。
Are they? Do you like French?
是吗？你喜欢法语吗？
Yes.
喜欢。
How many years have you done French?
你学了几年法语了？
I think this will be my sixth.
我想这应该是第六年了。
Oh, you've done a lot of French. Can you speak any? Say anything?
噢，你法语学得够久了。你会说点什么吗？说点什么？
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
（法语对话）
Very good. Good accent and well pronounced. Better than mine, I think.
非常好。口音很好，发音也很清晰。我想比我的好。
The fact that this nice lady is complimenting a teenager on his terrible accent, that's just her personal style. That is not part of the educational program. Mosi Secret has been looking into this program, and he explains what it was all about.
这位好心的女士在恭维一个青少年的可怕口音，那只是她个人的风格。那不是教育项目的一部分。Mosi Secret一直在研究这个项目，他解释了这是怎么一回事。
This interview was part of an experiment started by a white heiress from the South named Anne Forsyth. She was the granddaughter of a tobacco magnate, RJ Reynolds, and she saw that integration was happening all around the country except at prep schools in the South, and she wanted to do something about it. The students in these schools grow up to be the leaders of the South, she told Ebony magazine. Teach them to be less bigoted and they'd carry that attitude into the institutions they'd run someday. A small investment in an individual change could have a big effect. Meanwhile, the Black student she'd send into these boarding schools would get a top-notch education.
这次面试是一个由南方白人女继承人Anne Forsyth发起的实验的一部分。她是烟草大亨RJ Reynolds的孙女，她看到种族融合在全国各地都在进行，唯独除了南方的预科学校，她想做点什么。她告诉《Ebony》杂志，这些学校的学生长大后会成为南方的领导者。“教导他们少一些偏见，他们将来管理机构时就会把这种态度带进去。在一个个体改变上的小额投资可以产生巨大的影响。”与此同时，她派往这些寄宿学校的黑人学生将获得顶尖的教育。
So her little foundation set out to find the best of the best Black students, pluck them from their neighborhoods, convince previously all-white boarding schools to take them, and then send the students in as ambassadors.
所以她的基金会着手寻找最优秀的黑人学生，将他们从原来的社区挑选出来，说服以前全是白人的寄宿学校接收他们，然后将这些学生作为大使送进去。
Forsyth hired a man named John Ehle to lead the effort. John was a novelist from North Carolina who, in his 40s, turned his imagination to solving social problems with rich people's money. Rosemary Harris, the actress, was his wife. They went all over the South looking for applicants, interviewing them in their schools. John could be kind of gruff, even when he first sat down with someone. He talked to one boy who told John that his hobbies were chemistry and eating. "That's a hobby?" John asked.
Forsyth聘请了一个名叫John Ehle的人来领导这项工作。John是来自北卡罗来纳州的一位小说家，他在40多岁时将他的想象力转向利用富人的钱解决社会问题。女演员Rosemary Harris就是他的妻子。他们跑遍了南方寻找申请者，在学校里面试他们。John有时很粗鲁，即使是在第一次见到别人时。他和一个男孩交谈，男孩告诉John他的爱好是化学和吃饭。“那是爱好吗？”John问。
I love to eat.
我喜欢吃。
What do you like to eat most?
你最喜欢吃什么？
Well, I like to eat pizza.
嗯，我喜欢吃披萨。
What-- pizza. Oh, yeah, excuse me.
什——披萨。噢，对，抱歉。
French fries, cheeseburger, milk shakes.
炸薯条，芝士汉堡，奶昔。
Your taste in eating is no account at all, is it? Oh, my.
你的口味可真是一点品味都没有，不是吗？噢，天哪。
Another boy told John he was worried about the effects of studying too hard.
另一个男孩告诉John他担心学习太刻苦的影响。
But I believe I should study hard, but don't push myself to exhaustion till I get a nervous breakdown.
但我相信我应该努力学习，但不要把自己逼到筋疲力尽，直到神经崩溃。
You don't look like you're going to have one, if I may say so.
如果你允许我这么说，你看上去并不像是要崩溃的样子。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
You don't feel like you're going to have one soon, do you?
你并不觉得你很快会崩溃，对吗？
Mm-mm.
没。
I agree with you. Now these prep schools are harder than public schools.
我同意你的看法。现在这些预科学校比公立学校难多了。
All these kids you're hearing, they were all chosen. They went on to prep schools. And later in life, they became entrepreneurs and lawyers and engineers. But here, they were at a moment of great transition, about to become transplants who might or might not take.
你听到的所有这些孩子，他们都是被精挑细选的。他们去了预科学校。后来在生活中，他们成为了企业家、律师和工程师。但在这里，他们正处于一个巨大的转变时刻，即将成为可能成功也可能失败的“移植体”。
John and Rosemary don't tell the kids that this is an effort to change the minds of white students. The white students weren't told it, either. In fact, they wait until the end of these interviews to even bring up the fact that the candidates will be integrating white schools. They mention race, but they kind of back into it.
John和Rosemary没有告诉孩子们这是一个旨在改变白人学生想法的努力。白人学生也没被告知。事实上，他们直到面试结束才提及这些候选人将去整合白人学校的事实。他们提到了种族，但他们有点转弯抹角。
You want to go away to school?
你想去外地读书吗？
Yes.
想。
You wouldn't be homesick at school, would you?
你在学校不会感到思乡吧？
I don't think so.
我不觉得。
Are you worried at all about going to a-- because these are all-- these prep schools in the South are really all white. Does that idea bother you at all?
你担心去一所……因为这些……南方这些预科学校真的全是白人。那个想法困扰你吗？
No.
不。
What experience have you had with integration? This school isn't very integrated, is it?
你在种族融合方面有什么经验？这所学校整合程度不高，对吧？
No. In the sixth grade, I had a friend named Freedom, and he acts about as crazy as I do sometimes.
对。在六年级时，我有个朋友叫Freedom，他有时行动起来像我一样疯狂。
Uh-huh. Was he white?
嗯哼。他是白人吗？
Yes.
是的。
What was his name?
他叫什么名字？
Freedom.
Freedom。
Oh, that's rather a nice name.
噢，那是个挺不错的名字。
So you really don't find any difference between a white boy and a Black boy?
所以你真的觉得白人男孩和黑人男孩之间没什么区别吗？
No.
没区别。
If he's got the right qualities. That's good.
如果他有合适的品质。那很好。
Mm-mm.
嗯哼。
Go ahead and talk to Karen a minute, will you?
去和Karen谈一分钟吧，好吗？
OK.
好的。
John Ehle wanted this integration effort to happen quietly. No fuss, no big moments for the news cameras. "Stay out of the damn papers," he said. The first Stouffer recipients entered schools in the fall of 1967, 13 years after Brown versus Board of Education. There were 20 Black teenagers placed in seven private prep schools that year in small-town Virginia, in the mountains of Tennessee and North Carolina, on the affluent side of Atlanta, all schools that had historically only accepted white kids.
John Ehle希望这项融合努力能安静地进行。没有骚动，没有新闻摄像机的大场面。“远离那些该死的报纸，”他说。第一批Stouffer学生于1967年秋季进入学校，那是《布朗诉教育委员会案》之后的第13年。那一年，有20名黑人青少年被安置在弗吉尼亚州小镇、田纳西州和北卡罗来纳州山区的七所私立预科学校，还有亚特兰大富人区，所有这些学校在历史上都只接收白人孩子。
Does it bother you, the thought of going to a predominantly white boarding school?
去一所主要是白人的寄宿学校这个想法，困扰你吗？
No. I find that if you have a good sense of humor and you can get along with people well, it doesn't make any difference what race it is. If you can get along with people, get along with any type of people.
不。我发现如果你有幽默感，并且能和人相处得很好，那么种族是什么并不重要。如果你能和人相处，你就能和任何类型的人相处。
Sure. And if anybody is kind of unpleasant, you feel you can rise above it?
当然。如果有人很不讨人喜欢，你觉得你能超越它吗？
Yes.
是的。
Good. Not that you're going to have any difficulty, but.
很好。并不是说你会遇到任何困难，但是。
"Not that you're going to have any difficulty," Rosemary says, "but." Then her voice trails off.
“并不是说你会遇到任何困难，”Rosemary说，“但是。”然后她的声音减弱了。
So did this experiment work? Did it make white students less bigoted? And how'd it turn out for the Black students?
那么这个实验成功了吗？它使白人学生减少了偏见吗？这对那些黑人学生的结果又如何呢？
In order to answer those questions, I focused in on one school that took part in the Stouffer experiment, Virginia Episcopal School in Lynchburg, Virginia. People call it VES. When the Supreme Court mandated the desegregation of public schools, lawmakers in Virginia actually closed public schools rather than integrate in Charlottesville, Norfolk, and elsewhere, displacing more than 10,000 students. And white families enrolled their children in private schools in droves. VES was one of those schools. It was a haven for white families fleeing integration. That's what two Black Stouffer scholars were walking into when they arrived in 1967.
为了回答这些问题，我聚焦于一所参与Stouffer实验的学校：位于弗吉尼亚州林奇堡的弗吉尼亚圣公会学校（VES）。人们叫它VES。当最高法院裁定公立学校废除种族隔离时，弗吉尼亚州的立法者实际上关闭了夏洛茨维尔、诺福克等地的公立学校，而不是进行整合，导致一万多名学生流离失所。白人家庭蜂拥将孩子送入私立学校。VES就是其中之一。它是白人家庭逃避种族融合的避风港。这就是1967年两名黑人Stouffer学者到达时所面临的环境。
Bill Alexander was one of them. He was 14, from a middle-class family in segregated Nashville, the son of a prominent pastor, and a boy who John Ehle thought was perfect for Stouffer. After interviewing Bill, he wrote, "William Alexander, Jr. looks like a prep school student, dresses like one, and talks like one." In the fall of 1967, Bill flew to Lynchburg, walked outside the airport, and hailed a cab.
Bill Alexander是其中之一。他14岁，来自种族隔离的纳什维尔的一个中产家庭，是一位著名牧师的儿子，也是John Ehle认为Stouffer最完美的人选。在面试Bill后，他写道：“William Alexander, Jr.看起来像个预科学校学生，穿得像，谈吐也像。”1967年秋天，Bill飞到林奇堡，走出机场，拦了一辆出租车。
It was a Black cab driver. And I tell the cab driver, take me to VES, Virginia Episcopal School on VES Road. The cab driver drives off and takes me to downtown Lynchburg to an African-American Baptist seminary.
那是个黑人司机。我告诉司机，带我去VES，弗吉尼亚圣公会学校，VES路。司机开车走了，把我带到了林奇堡市中心的一个非裔美国人浸信会神学院。
Not VES.
不是VES。
He pulls up, and because I'd been up there, I knew where the school was. I said, well, sir, I said Virginia Episcopal School. He said, you're going there? He couldn't believe it. He couldn't process that.
他停下车，因为我之前去过那边，我知道学校在哪里。我说：“先生，我说的是弗吉尼亚圣公会学校。”他说：“你要去那儿？”他简直不敢相信。他处理不了这个事实。
Eventually, Bill made his way to VES, where he got a warm welcome.
最终，Bill到了VES，受到了热烈欢迎。
They knew I was coming. They came down. They had some guys come get my bags and stuff. The leaders of the school came down. They said, welcome, Bill. Let me take you to your room.
他们知道我要来。他们下来了。他们派人来帮我拿行李之类的。学校的领导下来了。他们说：“欢迎，Bill。让我带你去你的房间。”
Bill's new roommate, Marvin Barnard, arrived in Lynchburg by bus. He'd come by himself, 100 miles from the Black side of Richmond. He had one suitcase. He was wearing a sports jacket, a little blue cap. He'd never seen a place like VES before.
Bill的新室友Marvin Barnard是坐巴士到林奇堡的。他独自一人，从里士满的黑人区走了100英里。他有一个手提箱。他穿着运动夹克，戴着一顶蓝色小帽子。他从未见过像VES这样的地方。
It had a bell tower. The bell tower, I thought, was beautiful. I never had a bell tower in the community where I came from. The lawn was rolling. The mountains in the background. It was so peaceful. And I felt like, OK, I can do this. Of course, I had no idea. I didn't really realize how big an issue this really was in terms of integrating the school. I wasn't thinking along that line at 13 and 14 years old. I was thinking that it's a big experiment. People want you to come. People in my community wanted me to go. I'm ready to go. Let's get it going.
它有一个钟楼。我觉得钟楼很美。我出生的社区里从来没有过钟楼。草坪连绵起伏。远处是群山。它如此宁静。我当时感觉，好吧，我能做到。当然，我一无所知。在13、14岁时，我并没有意识到在学校融合这件事上这意味着多大的问题。我当时想的是，这只是个大实验。人们希望你去。我社区里的人希望我去。我准备好了。让我们开始吧。
Marvin was smiley, 5" 2', 100 pounds. During his interview with John Ehle, he told John, "I get along with everyone," which was true. He did.
Marvin总是面带微笑，5英尺2英寸，100磅。在与John Ehle的面试中，他告诉John：“我能和任何人相处”，这是真的。他的确做到了。
Unfortunately, there aren't recordings of Bill and Marvin's interviews. In many ways, Marvin was Bill's opposite, warm-blooded to Bill's cool, short to Bill's tall. Marvin grew up in a three-room shack with an outside toilet, not a middle-class home like Bill. A teacher would come to call the duo of Marvin and Bill Fire and Ice.
不幸的是，没有Bill和Marvin面试的录音。在许多方面，Marvin与Bill截然相反，Bill冷静，Marvin热情；Bill高大，Marvin矮小。Marvin成长在一个带室外厕所的三室小屋里，而不是像Bill那样的中产阶级家庭。一位老师把这一对叫作“火与冰”。
Both Bill and Marvin had a vague sense, a 14-year-old sense, that integrating VES was a small way they could participate in the civil rights movement they saw happening all around them. 1967 was the year that riots broke out in more than 100 cities across the country. The Supreme Court decided Loving versus the State of Virginia, which ended laws against interracial marriage. John Ehle told Marvin that this was a chance to prove that Black students could perform as well as any white students if the playing field were level.
Bill和Marvin都有一种模糊的、14岁孩子的感觉，认为整合VES是他们参与当时随处可见的民权运动的一种微小方式。1967年，全美有100多个城市爆发了骚乱。最高法院裁定了《洛文诉弗吉尼亚州案》，结束了禁止跨种族婚姻的法律。John Ehle告诉Marvin，这是一个证明如果比赛场地公平，黑人学生可以和任何白人学生表现得一样好的机会。
VES was a vestige of a Jim Crow South on land that had once been a plantation. A decade or so before Bill and Marvin arrived, VES had decided to tear down the remaining slave cabin on campus. But they had a new headmaster, a guy from the north who had opened the door when The Stouffer Foundation came knocking.
VES是种族隔离时期南方的一个残余，坐落在曾经的种植园土地上。Bill和Marvin到达前十年左右，VES决定拆除校园里仅剩的奴隶小屋。但他们换了一位校长，一个来自北方的人，他在Stouffer基金会敲门时打开了大门。
Resistance came from parents and some of the board. "Why, why, why have you done this cruel thing to our beloved school?" one parent wrote. "A private boarding school like VES is an extension, a part of the family. We have no intention whatsoever of integrating those of another race into our family." Stouffer wasn't blind to the immense challenges Marvin and Bill would face. So as a way to prep them, all 20 Stouffer scholars did a summer program at Duke. They learned both academics and manners, how to read classic books, do advanced math, hold a tennis racket, swim. Here's Marvin.
抗议来自家长和一些董事会成员。“为什么，为什么，为什么要对我们心爱的学校做这种残忍的事？”一位家长写道。“像VES这样的私立寄宿学校是家庭的延伸，家庭的一部分。我们完全没有意愿将其他种族的人整合进我们的家庭。”Stouffer并没有忽视Marvin和Bill将面临的巨大挑战。所以作为预备工作，所有20名Stouffer学者都在杜克大学参加了一个暑期项目。他们学习学术和礼仪，如何阅读经典书籍，做高等数学，拿网球拍，游泳。这是Marvin。
Socially, they really gave us a heads-up in terms of what dormitory life may be like, in a dormitory where there were, obviously, white students and they may pull pranks on you. And I wasn't used to-- like, what's a prank? A prank's, you know, you do your little things, and it sort of jokes around and they laugh about it. And I'm like, meh, OK. But my main thing is like, I've got to be a good student.
在社交方面，他们确实给我们打了个预防针，让我们知道宿舍生活可能是怎样的——在明显有白人学生的宿舍里，他们可能会对你搞恶作剧。我过去不习惯……什么是恶作剧？恶作剧就是，你知道，你做点小动作，然后大家笑笑，把它当作玩笑。我就觉得，好吧，随他们吧。但我主要的任务是——我必须做一个好学生。
So it sounds like you're saying there was very little discussion of race there, despite what you were going off to do.
所以听起来你是说，尽管你要去做那件事，但那里几乎没有关于种族的讨论。
Yeah. I don't recall that.
是的。我记不起来有。
Instead, they were told if someone pranks you, don't assume that it's about race. They left it up to the kids to figure out.
相反，他们被告知如果有人搞恶作剧，不要假设那是因为种族。他们让孩子们自己去弄清楚。
Sort of try to feel out whether things were primarily because you were a new student versus is certain things happening because you're a Black student.
试着感受一下事情的主要原因是你是新来的学生，还是因为你是黑人学生而发生的。
Freshmen at VES were known as newboys or rats. And once they were at VES, Marvin and Bill experienced some of the same mild hazing that happened to white freshmen. Seniors would tell them to get in the back of the line in the cafeteria. They'd make them do their laundry. They rolled with it, but it never escaped their minds that they were the only two Black students on campus. They became a team, friends and roommates who were going to shine. Here's Marvin.
VES的新生被称为“新男孩”或“老鼠”。一旦到了VES，Marvin和Bill也经历了一些白人新生经历过的温和的欺凌。高年级学生会告诉他们在食堂排在队尾。他们会让他们洗衣服。他们随遇而安，但他们从未忘记自己是校园里唯一的两名黑人学生。他们成为了一个团队，作为朋友和室友，他们要大放异彩。这是Marvin。
I felt that, if I was a good student, to be the best student I could be, then there would be success. And Bill and I both knew, then-- I think everybody else-- we wanted to be good students in as many things as possible. Not just in the classroom, but in the dorms, on the field, whatever we could do.
我觉得，如果我是一个好学生，尽我所能成为最好的学生，那么成功就会到来。我和Bill都知道——我想其他人也是——我们想在尽可能多的事情上成为好学生。不仅在教室里，还在宿舍里，在运动场上，无论我们能做什么。
Right out of the gate, Bill and Marvin did more than anyone thought they could ever do. After a month into the first semester, the school's headmaster, Austin Montgomery, wrote a letter to the Foundation with an update on the boy's progress. It started, "As I write, the two are playing touch with a dozen others out on the lovely front campus. I thought you might be interested that Friday, unbeknownst to me, the freshmen held class elections." Austin explained that the white kids had chosen Bill to be freshman class president, and that was after losing the Black vote. Marvin had voted for someone else.
刚开始，Bill和Marvin的表现就超过了任何人以为他们能做到的程度。第一学期过了一个月，学校校长Austin Montgomery给基金会写了一封信，通报了这两个男孩的进步。“我写信时，这两个孩子正和十几个人在漂亮的草坪上玩橄榄球。我以为你会感兴趣，周五，在我不知情的情况下，新生们举行了班级选举。”Austin解释说，白人孩子选择了Bill担任新生班长，那还是在失去了黑人选票之后（Marvin投给了别人）。
After the end of the first semester, when everyone gathered around the bulletin board in Jett Hall to look at their grades and see where they stood, Bill and Marvin were out ahead, tied for number one, more than 40 white boys in their class in line behind them.
第一学期结束后，当大家聚在Jett大厅的公告板前查看成绩并了解自己的排名时，Bill和Marvin遥遥领先，并列第一，排在他们身后的有40多名白人学生。
I'm sure several were shocked. Yeah, there was a little competition going on.
我肯定有好几个人感到震惊。是的，当时有一点竞争。
Things continued like this into the next semester. Mostly great, but not entirely.
接下来的学期情况也是如此。大部分时间很棒，但并非完全如此。
There may have been different events where you may hear individuals use the n-word while you're walking down the hall and you turn around and nobody would say anything, and everybody looking like, well, who said that? Or you go into a study hall in the classroom where you normally sit-- most people have habits of where they sit and where they study or whatever-- and there's a little note that has the n-word on it. So those were minor, trivial types of things that I really didn't put a lot of stock in at all.
可能发生过一些事件，你在走廊里走的时候可能会听到有人用“N”开头的那个贬义词，你回过头去，没人会说什么，大家都摆出一副“谁说的？”的样子。或者你走进通常坐的教室里——大多数人都有坐那儿学习的习惯——上面有一张小纸条，写着那个贬义词。所以这些都是一些轻微的、琐碎的事情，我真的没太在意。
Marvin said he'd been told by the uncle who raised him not to worry about words. "As long as they don't get physical with you. Don't let them hit my son, now." Marvin says when these things would happen, he'd think to himself, is that the best you got?
Marvin说，养育他的叔叔告诉他不要为言语所动。“只要他们不跟你动武就行。别让他们打我的儿子。”Marvin说，当这些事情发生时，他会想：这就是你们能做到的最好程度了吗？
Then a Thursday night, April 4, 1968, and Bill and Marvin were in their dorm room.
然后是一个周四的晚上，1968年4月4日，Bill和Marvin在他们的宿舍房间里。
And then the announcement came over the radio that Martin Luther King had been shot.
然后收音机里传来了消息，马丁·路德·金被枪杀了。
He entered to the hospital emergency room with his face covered with a towel. The exact extent of his injuries not known at this time.
他进入医院急诊室时脸盖着毛巾。目前尚不清楚他的伤势程度。
And when it was announced over the radio, all of a sudden, I could hear nothing but laughter all throughout the dormitory halls. And it sort of resonated not only in our hallway, but it seemed like it was resonating through all the dorms.
当收音机里宣布这个消息时，突然间，我听到整个宿舍走廊里全是笑声。那种声音不仅仅在我们走廊里，似乎在所有宿舍里都产生了共鸣。
At least, that's what it sounded like to Marvin.
至少，Marvin听起来是这样。
I mean, when I heard that, I just got so angry and hurt by it because it was so pervasive. I thought it was very disrespectful. Why are you laughing when he's announcing that someone has been killed? And it's like, why are you like joyous? You're celebrating.
我的意思是，当我听到那个时，我感到非常愤怒和受伤，因为它太普遍了。我认为那非常不尊重人。有人被杀，为什么要笑？为什么你们表现得那么快乐？你们在庆祝。
One of the guys on the floor, he came, and he was laughing. Came by the room and was taunting.
楼层里的一个人过来嘲笑我们。
This is Bill. He doesn't remember exactly what was said.
这是Bill。他不记得具体说了什么。
No, I don't remember, but I mean, ah, he's dead. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. It was probably that. He's dead. Good. I'm glad he was killed.
不，我不记得了，但大概是，“啊，他死了。哈，哈，哈，哈，哈，哈。”很可能是那样。“他死了。好。我很高兴他被杀了。”
They were happy. Them people were happy. They were glad he was shot.
他们很高兴。那些人很高兴。他们很高兴他被枪杀了。
And with all that laughter going on, I remember looking at Bill and it was like, I can't let this go. And I went out into the hallway and I demanded that anybody that thinks that this is funny, that you need to come out and face me now. If you think this is funny and you want to laugh, come out and face me now. And there was silence. Nothing happened.
当那些笑声持续不断时，我记得看着Bill，我觉得我不能让这件事过去。我走到走廊里，质问任何觉得这件事好笑的人，“你们现在必须出来面对我。如果你觉得好笑，如果你想笑，现在就出来面对我。”然后是沉默。什么也没发生。
The night of Martin Luther King's assassination, there was one person who stood up for Bill and Marvin, someone who stepped up in a way that, even now, when they look back on it, feels significant, their headmaster, Austin Montgomery. Austin died in 1995. But that night, he called all the students into the chapel. Again, here's Bill.
马丁·路德·金遇刺那天晚上，有一个人站出来支持Bill和Marvin，有人以一种即使现在回想起来仍然意义重大的方式站了出来，他们的校长，Austin Montgomery。Austin于1995年去世。但那天晚上，他把所有学生都叫到了礼堂。再听一遍，这是Bill。
We've gone to bed. We're in our PJs. And then we get the call. "Everybody come to chapel." So all the guys are in chapel in their PJs. And Mr. Montgomery gave one of the best speeches I've ever seen in my life.
我们已经上床睡觉了。我们穿着睡衣。然后我们接到了通知。“大家都来礼堂。”所以所有学生都穿着睡衣在礼堂里。Montgomery先生发表了我一生中看过的最精彩的演讲之一。
In short, he was saying that the life of any man should not be one that there should be laughter or joy over, and this is not the VES way. And we are not going to have this here.
简而言之，他在说任何人的生命都不应该引发笑声或喜悦，这不是VES的作风。我们绝不允许这种情况在这里发生。
He said, we're better than this. And he wasn't going to tolerate that foolishness.
他说，我们比这更好。他绝不容忍那种愚蠢的行为。
That night had a profound effect on Bill and Marvin. Here's Marvin.
那天晚上对Bill和Marvin产生了深远的影响。这是Marvin。
It did carve-- it carved something deep inside of me because these are some of the same people that we had, quote, unquote, "been friendly with" and everything else, and why would they do that? Is there something that I don't know? Was I being just deceived or deluded in how I was thinking? That's where the whole aspect, in terms of the young, smiley face, great experiment, everybody's buying into it, that took a different shade that evening.
它确实刻下了……它在我内心深处刻下了一些东西，因为这些人中的一些正是我们所谓的“友好”相处的人，为什么他们会那样做？有什么我不了解的事情吗？我是被欺骗或被蒙蔽了吗？那就是那个年轻、笑脸、伟大的实验，大家都买账的这一整件事，在那天晚上呈现出了另一种色彩。
Marvin's roommate, Bill, was angry, too. But true to form, Ice kept it to himself. And he had this additional reaction to it. He found the incident clarifying.
Marvin的室友Bill也很愤怒。但确实如他的一贯作风，“冰”将其埋在心里。他对这件事还有额外的反应。他觉得这起事件让一切变得清晰了。
How can I say this at my age? I did not have an expectation that I'm coming to VES and that it's going to be a post-racial experience. I think we could make things different, and hopefully for the better, sure, but I'm not going to take that weight on. Oh, my God, you don't like me. Or you expressed your bias against African-Americans because you laughed when Dr. King was assassinated. OK, well, I know who you are. OK. We're good.
我到这个年纪该怎么说呢？我没有指望我来到VES会是一个没有种族偏见的体验。我想我们可以让事情变得不同，希望是往好的方面，当然，但我不会承担那个重担。噢，天哪，你不喜欢我。或者你因为马丁·路德·金被刺杀而笑，表现出了对非裔美国人的偏见。好吧，没关系。我知道你是谁了。好吧。我们很好。
That summer, Marvin returned home, back to his old life, back to the shotgun house he grew up in in Fulton, a neighborhood in Richmond, Virginia. Some people called it Fulton Bottom because it was at the bottom of a hill on the banks of the James River. White people seldom came down the hill. One night, Marvin was in his house where he lived with his uncle. His aunt had died a few years before. Marvin was laying on the couch, watching his uncle, the man who had raised him, the man he called dad, smoke a cigarette on the front porch.
那个夏天，Marvin回到家，回到他原来的生活中，回到他长大的位于弗吉尼亚州里士满的富尔顿社区的那座枪型屋。有些人叫它“富尔顿底部”，因为它位于詹姆斯河岸边的一座山下。白人很少下山。一天晚上，Marvin躺在沙发上，看着他的叔叔，那个抚养他的人，他称之为爸爸的人，在门廊上抽烟。
And I could see his body, his silhouette outside the window. A little breeze coming on a warm July night. The screen door opens, and he comes in. He's walking real slow. And he just sort of flops down. And as he flops down, I had to sort of pull my legs up real quick, otherwise he would've sat on my legs.
我可以看到他在窗外的轮廓。暖和的七月夜晚，吹着微风。纱门开了，他进来了。他走得很慢。然后他扑通一声坐了下来。当他扑通坐下时，我不得不迅速把腿收起来，否则他就会坐在我的腿上。
And I'm thinking, Dad wouldn't just sit on my legs like that. What's wrong? And then he says, you know, you're doing very well. He says, I'm proud of you. You're a good young man. And I said, well, thanks, Dad. So he says to me, I want you to go and sleep in the big bed.
我在想，爸爸不会那样坐在我腿上的。怎么了？然后他说：“你知道吗，你做得很好。”他说：“我为你感到骄傲。你是个好小伙子。”我说：“好吧，谢谢，爸爸。”于是他对我讲：“我想让你去睡那张大床。”
Marvin usually slept on the cot in the middle room. It was the man of the house who slept in the big bed.
Marvin通常睡在中间房间的小床上。睡大床的是家里的男主人。
So I go into the bedroom where the big bed, his bed, is, and I get ready to turn off the light. And as I get ready to turn off the light, I just hear this harsh sound. A gasp. And so I go back into the room and I see him, and I know he's gone. And then I just closed his eyes.
所以我走进放着那张大床——他的床——的卧室，准备关灯。就在我准备关灯时，我听到了一种刺耳的声音。一声喘息。于是我回到房间，看见他，我知道他走了。然后我就闭上了他的眼睛。
Marvin was now all alone, no close family to turn to, grieving. Then he got a letter from Headmaster Austin Montgomery, offering his sympathy and urging Marvin to return to school in the fall. "I hope you know, Marvin, what deep respect and affection and what high hopes I have for you. I think you took hold of what could have been a difficult situation this past year and handled it manfully in the very best sense of that word. You did yourself great credit. I hope that you had a happy year, and one that you think was profitable. Probably you did at least as much for VES as it did for you. Let me say that, whether it matters to you or not, the school needs you, and you at your very best, working and playing hard and speaking up with humor and wisdom for what you think is right and important."
Marvin现在孤身一人，没有亲近的家人可以依靠，处于悲痛之中。然后他收到了一封校长Austin Montgomery的信，表达慰问并敦促Marvin秋季返校。“Marvin，希望你知道我对你有多么深的敬意和喜爱，以及多么高的期待。我认为你把过去一年可能是一个困难的情况处理得非常有男子气概，这个词最好的意义上。你为自己赢得了极大的荣誉。希望你度过了快乐的一年，并且你认为这一年是富有成效的。可能VES从你身上学到的和你从VES那里学到的一样多。让我说，无论这对你是否重要，学校需要你，需要你在最好的状态，努力学习、努力玩耍，并以幽默和智慧为你认为正确和重要的事情仗义执言。”
The fall of 1968, Marvin returned for his sophomore year. Bill, too. But Headmaster Austin Montgomery was gone. The details aren't totally clear, but it seems like there was pressure on him to leave. Austin was a Northerner with a bristly temperament, and he'd pushed the school to integrate. His replacement was a Southerner, an institutional guy who played by the rules.
1968年秋季，Marvin回到了他的高二。Bill也是。但校长Austin Montgomery离开了。细节不完全清楚，但似乎学校对他有压力，让他离开。Austin是一个脾气暴躁的北方人，他推动了学校的融合。接替他的是一个南方人，一个遵循规则的建制派。
But before Austin left, he made sure the Stouffer experiment continued with two new Black students joining Marvin and Bill that fall, two boys they looked after and checked in on. And the experiment started to shape who Marvin was. He became a little more fire. He grew more militant.
但在Austin离开之前，他确保了Stouffer实验得以延续，那年秋天，两名新的黑人学生加入了Marvin和Bill的行列，那是他们照顾和留意的两个男孩。这个实验开始塑造Marvin。他变得更像“火”了。他变得更激进了。
I grew a bigger Afro, which also gave me some height.
我留了一个更大的非洲发型，这也给了我一些身高。
Partly in response to white students who decorated their rooms with the Confederate flag, Marvin started wearing dashikis, and--
部分是为了回应那些用邦联旗装饰房间的白人学生，Marvin开始穿非洲式短袍（dashiki），而且……
My facial expressions were different, like I'm looking at you right now. And I was looking like I could hurt you if you step on me. OK. It's like, yeah, you're my bud and everything like that, but you don't tread on me, OK? You don't disrespect me.
我的表情也不同了，就像我现在看着你一样。我看起来就像如果你惹我，我就会伤害你。好的，就像是：是的，你是我的伙伴，一切都好，但你别惹我，好的？别不尊重我。
Meanwhile, they doubled down on proving they were the best. They were defiant.
与此同时，他们加倍努力证明自己是最棒的。他们充满反抗。
It definitely made me want to work even harder. And I wanted to make a statement by making a bigger gap between our being number one and number two and whoever was three and four. I didn't want it to be perceived that it was something that was an aberration. It was very close. And that's how we could really fight. We could really fight by being better students.
这绝对让我更想努力工作。我想通过拉大我们第一名和第二名，与第三、第四名之间的差距来发表声明。我不希望人们认为这只是某种反常现象。这真的很接近。那就是我们真正可以战斗的方式。我们可以通过成为更好的学生来战斗。
It worked. Bill and Marvin were popular, good athletes, exceptional students, guys everyone at VES looked up to. Bill lettered early, showed up his sophomore year with his varsity jacket. They were football champions one year, dorm leaders another year, friends with the white guys. Bill and Marvin held the number one and number two academic rankings all four years they were at VES, the pinnacle of Anne Forsyth's hopes. They chipped away at white supremacy by being supreme.
成功了。Bill和Marvin很受欢迎，是优秀的运动员，出色的学生，每个人都敬佩他们。Bill早早就获得了校队资格，大二时就穿上了 varsity 夹克。他们一年是足球冠军，一年是宿舍领导，和白人男孩也是朋友。Bill和Marvin在VES的四年里始终保持着学术排名的第一和第二，这是Anne Forsyth希望的巅峰。他们通过让自己达到巅峰，削弱了白人至上主义。
I got to feel the real impact of all of this about a year ago when I went to VES for the school's 100-year reunion. Walking around campus with Bill and Marvin was like being with celebrities. Every few paces, a former classmate would stop them and offer kind words, give them a slap on the back.
大约一年前，当我为了学校的百年校庆去VES时，我真正感受到了这一切的影响。和Bill、Marvin一起在校园里走动就像和名人在一起。每走几步，一位前同学就会拦住他们，说几句客套话，拍拍他们的背。
Good to see you, Marvin! I thought I recognized you.
很高兴见到你，Marvin！我想我认出你了。
In the main building on campus, there's a display that commemorates Marvin and Bill. There's photos of them from their freshman and senior years, like a before and after.
在校园的主楼里，有一个纪念Marvin和Bill的展览。有他们大一和大四的照片，就像前后对比图。
I want you to pay attention to 1967. See how we come in? Look at the bright eyes, and we're all happy.
我想让你关注1967年。看看我们是怎么进来的？看看那些明亮的眼睛，我们都很快乐。
Bill with some schoolboy glasses on and a suit. Short, trimmed hair. You with a plaid jacket.
Bill戴着书呆子眼镜，穿着西装。头发剪得很短。你穿着格子夹克。
That's right. We were just happy to be here.
没错。我们只是很高兴来到这里。
The reunion was the first time that most of the Stouffer students had been together again since Bill and Marvin's senior year. By the time they were seniors, there were seven Black students at VES. They took to calling themselves The Magnificent Seven. That weekend, those who were there were honored and got a standing ovation.
那是自Bill和Marvin高四以来，大多数Stouffer学生第一次重聚。到他们高四时，VES有七名黑人学生。他们开始称自己为“辉煌七杰”（The Magnificent Seven）。那个周末，那些到场的人受到了表彰，并获得了全场起立鼓掌。
[INAUDIBLE]
（听不清）
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
But something else happened that weekend at the reunion, something that reveals a different side of this social experiment. Some of the guys in The Magnificent Seven were hoping they could take a photograph of all seven of them together, and they kept asking me about one person, a guy who was missing, Johnny Halloway. Johnny was one of the two Black students who came to VES the year after Bill and Marvin.
但那个周末在重聚时还发生了别的事，揭示了这个社会实验的不同侧面。“辉煌七杰”中的一些人希望能把他们七个人聚在一起拍张照，他们一直问我一个人，一个缺席的人，Johnny Halloway。Johnny是Bill和Marvin入学后一年来到VES的两名黑人学生之一。
Is Johnny-- did you get up with Johnny? You didn't get up with Johnny Halloway, did you?
Johnny……你联系上Johnny了吗？你没有联系上Johnny Halloway吧？
That's Terry Sherrill, one of The Magnificent Seven, asking me about Johnny.
那是Terry Sherrill，“辉煌七杰”之一，问我关于Johnny的事。
I spoke with Johnny.
我联系过Johnny。
You did speak to him?
你确实和他联系过了？
Yeah.
是的。
Did he say he was coming?
他说他要来吗？
Johnny is not coming.
Johnny不来。
I'd gotten in touch with Johnny while reporting this story. I told Terry that Johnny was now a pastor at a church in Durham, North Carolina.
我在报道这个故事时联系过Johnny。我告诉Terry，Johnny现在是北卡罗来纳州达勒姆一家教堂的牧师。
Do you know the name of the church? Because we're thinking about trying to go up there maybe Sunday and surprise him at his church.
你知道教堂的名字吗？因为我们正在考虑周日去那里，也许能在他的教堂给他一个惊喜。
Wow.
哇。
If we could get the details of his church, we will go.
如果我们能得到他教堂的详细信息，我们就会去。
Maybe you can hear in my voice, I didn't think Johnny would like that surprise because Johnny, he was not Bill and Marvin. He did not celebrate VES the way they did.
也许你能从我的声音里听出来，我不认为Johnny会喜欢那个惊喜，因为Johnny，他不是Bill和Marvin。他不像他们那样赞美VES。
Coming up, what exactly happened to Johnny? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，Johnny到底发生了什么？从芝加哥公共广播电台收听我们的节目，稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Essay B. What happens when you create a project whose main goal is to integrate schools for the benefit of the white students there? How does that work out for everybody? If you're just tuning in, we're in the middle of a story by reporter Mosi Secret. He also did a version of this story this week for The New York Times Magazine. That's at nytimes.com/integration.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“作文B”。当你创造一个主要目标是为了整合学校以造福其中的白人学生时，会发生什么？这对每个人来说结果如何？如果你刚开始收听，我们正在听记者Mosi Secret带来的故事。他本周也为《纽约时报杂志》制作了这个故事的一个版本。请访问 nytimes.com/integration。
Right before the break, Mosi was explaining that a guy named Johnny Halloway decided not to return to VES for their reunion for reasons of his own. Mosi picks up the story from there.
在休息之前，Mosi解释说，一个叫Johnny Halloway的人因为自己的原因决定不回VES参加重聚。Mosi从那里继续讲。
A month before, I'd gotten on the phone with Johnny, and pretty quickly, he told me this.
一个月前，我通过电话联系了Johnny，他很快就告诉了我这个。
I took a lot of beatings. I don't know if anyone else has spoken about that.
我挨了很多打。我不知道还有没有别人提到过这一点。
No, they hadn't. Johnny told me he was beaten several times, always by the same guys, and he was certain it was racially motivated. He said he never told the other Black students about it. He said there was no point. So I went to visit Johnny at his church to talk more about this.
不，他们没有。Johnny告诉我，他曾多次被殴打，总是被同一伙人，他确信这是出于种族动机。他说他从没告诉过其他黑人学生。他说没意义。所以我去Johnny的教堂探望他，谈论更多相关内容。
Johnny's church is called Cup of Salvation. It's a storefront church in Durham, North Carolina off a state highway in a complex with a bingo hall, daycare center, and a beauty salon. At first, Johnny didn't want to go into details about what happened. But eventually, he told me what those beatings were like.
Johnny的教堂叫“救恩之杯”（Cup of Salvation）。它是北卡罗来纳州达勒姆的一家临街教堂，就在一条州道旁，综合体里还有一个宾果大厅、托儿所和美容院。起初，Johnny不想进入细节谈论发生的事。但最终，他告诉了我那些殴打是怎么回事。
If you could imagine yourself being in bed, asleep, and somebody throwing your sheet over your head and you're suddenly being pummeled by a bunch of guys. That's pretty intense. At 14 years old, feeling that you have no sanctuary at all, feeling that you're really not safe from getting beat up, and that you're doing it not just for yourself, but for a movement that's larger than yourself, taking that kind of beating, and it hurts when you get hit.
如果你能想象自己躺在床上，睡着了，有人把床单蒙在你头上，你突然被一群家伙一顿猛揍。那是相当激烈的。在14岁时，感到自己没有任何避难所，感到自己真的无法避免被揍，而且你做这件事不仅仅是为了你自己，而是为了一个比你自身更大的运动，承受那种殴打，被打的时候很痛。
Then you don't sleep the rest of the night because you don't know if they're coming back. You're crying. You're angry. You're hurt.
然后你整晚都不敢睡，因为你不知道他们还会不会再来。你在哭。你很愤怒。你很受伤。
The next day, when you go out to breakfast, you're looking around, trying to see if you can identify everybody that did it because of how maybe they're looking at you. You wonder if everybody else knows, and if they're laughing behind your back. It's humiliating, but it also it made me angry. It made me hostile in some ways.
第二天，当你出去吃早餐时，你环顾四周，试图确认每一个做这件事的人，因为他们看你的方式。你想知道其他人是否都知道，他们是否在背后嘲笑你。这很羞辱人，但也让我很愤怒。这在某些方面让我变得敌对。
After his freshman year, things got better for Johnny. The upperclassmen who beat him graduated. He settled in, sang in the glee club, made new friends. He learned that he could perform as well or better than white people. The beatings, that was just one part of his experience at VES.
高一之后，Johnny的情况变好了。殴打他的高年级学生毕业了。他安顿下来，在合唱团唱歌，交了新朋友。他学到他能和白人一样甚至更好。那些殴打只是他在VES经历的一部分。
I was pretty aware that I was going to be an ambassador, a pioneer, a lab rat. So I was pretty aware that what I was being asked to do was bigger than me. But I didn't really want to be a racial ambassador. I just wanted to be a kid growing up, going to school.
我很清楚我将成为一名大使，一名先驱，一只小白鼠。所以我很清楚被要求做的事比我本身大得多。但我真的不想当什么种族大使。我只是想做一个成长、上学的孩子。
I explained to him that one of the goals of the program was to teach white kids about Black people-- to benefit the white guys, like the bullies who came into his room at night. The fact that he was beat up is part of that experiment, The Foundation never knew about that.
我向他解释说，该项目的目标之一是教育白人孩子了解黑人——造福白人男生，比如那些晚上闯入他房间的恶霸。他被打的事实是那个实验的一部分，基金会从来不知道这一点。
I don't recall anybody from The Stouffer Foundation talking to me at all after I was admitted into VES. And I could be wrong about that, but I don't recall ever having a conversation with anyone to follow up and see how was I doing, how was it working out or whatever. So I did feel, at that point, like I had been thrown into this thing and then, if it works, it works. If it doesn't, it doesn't.
我不记得Stouffer基金会有任何人在我进入VES后跟我交谈过。我可能记错了，但我印象中没有和任何人有过跟进对话，看看我做得怎么样，进展如何之类的。所以我当时确实觉得，就像被扔进了这个实验中，如果行得通就行，行不通就算了。
But I didn't feel used. I didn't blame them. I felt like they had given me an opportunity and I appreciated the opportunity.
但我并没有感到被利用。我不怪他们。我觉得他们给了我一个机会，我很感激这个机会。
Johnny reluctantly told me two names of people who had beaten him. One of the guys is dead. I tried the other multiple times, but he didn't respond. I talked to Johnny's roommate from the time, and he confirmed that this happened. He said it happened to him, too. He told me there was one guy who was so racist, so hostile towards him, that he had fantasies of pushing the kid off the dorm roof.
Johnny不情愿地告诉了我两个殴打他的人的名字。其中一个人已经去世了。我多次联系另一个人，但他没有回应。我采访了当时Johnny的室友，他证实了这件事发生过。他说这也发生在他身上。他告诉我有一个人种族歧视非常严重，对他非常有敌意，以至于他曾幻想把那个家伙从宿舍屋顶推下去。
Anne Forsyth and The Stouffer Foundation eventually ran out of money in 1976. In the '70s, there were just a few more Black students. Eventually, more Black students started going to VES in the '80s. Not through any formal effort-- more people just started applying. And today, a little less than 9% of the student population is Black. There are other students of color, as well. Two of the Stouffer scholars have been on the board at VES. Bill has a scholarship for Black students in his name. So one of the goals of Stouffer-- integrating these schools-- that's happened in 20 schools. Another-- providing opportunity for Black students-- that's the clearest victory in this effort.
Anne Forsyth和Stouffer基金会在1976年最终耗尽了资金。70年代，只有少数黑人学生加入。最终，80年代越来越多的黑人学生开始去VES。不是通过什么正式努力——只是越来越多的人开始申请。今天，大约不到9%的学生群体是黑人。也有其他有色人种学生。Stouffer学者中有两人曾在VES董事会任职。Bill以他的名义为黑人学生设立了奖学金。所以Stouffer的目标之一——整合这些学校——已经在20所学校实现了。另一个——为黑人学生提供机会——这是该项目中胜利最明显的一点。
Marvin and Bill are both doctors now. Bill went to Harvard. Marvin decided to go to the best historically Black college in the country, Howard University. He was tired of representing all Black people. Among the other 140 Stouffer scholars, there are doctors, lawyers, a political operative, a judge, teachers, corporate leaders. But what about the goal that made Anne Forsyth want to do this in the first place-- the idea that this would change the hearts and minds of white students? Someone did try to measure this.
Marvin和Bill现在都是医生。Bill去了哈佛。Marvin决定去全国最好的历史上黑人大学，霍华德大学。他厌倦了代表所有黑人。在其他140名Stouffer学者中，有医生、律师、政治幕僚、法官、教师、企业领导。但是，Anne Forsyth最初发起这一切的目标呢？那种认为这会改变白人学生心智的想法？有人尝试衡量过这一点。
In 1973, John Ehle commissioned a survey of students' attitudes about race in the prep schools they integrated, but it wasn't scientifically done. And a few students wrote letters asking things like, why the questionnaire on Black students when there are only three in the whole school?
1973年，John Ehle委托对他们整合的预科学校中学生的种族态度进行了一项调查，但那并非科学所为。一些学生写信询问诸如“当学校里总共只有三个黑人学生时，为什么还要对黑人学生进行问卷调查？”这样的问题。
We conducted our own unscientific survey and called around to a bunch of white VES alums. Most didn't want to engage the question at all. They didn't want to talk about race head-on. We heard a lot of polite dodges about how color didn't mean anything or we didn't see them as Black. We saw them as classmates. Or I don't remember it being an issue.
我们进行了自己不科学的调查，给一群白人VES校友打了电话。大多数人根本不想介入这个问题。他们不想直接谈论种族。我们听到了很多委婉的闪躲，比如“肤色什么也不代表”或者“我们没把他们看作黑人。我们看作是同学”。或者“我不记得这有什么问题”。
But I was able to find one guy who seemed changed and who was game to talk about it. John Harman, class of '72, the same class as Johnny Halloway, the guy who didn't show up at reunion. John Harman came to VES from Tazewell, Virginia, a town of about 4,000. Growing up, the legacy of Jim Crow was all around him. His family used to go to the theater on Main Street, where Blacks had to sit in the balcony. His father was a lawyer who used the town's Confederate soldier statue as a landmark.
但我找到了一个人，他似乎改变了，并且愿意谈论它。John Harman，72届毕业生，和Johnny Halloway同一届，就是那个没参加重聚的人。John Harman是从弗吉尼亚州Tazewell来到VES的，那是一个约有4000人的小镇。成长过程中，种族隔离的遗产随处可见。他的家人以前去主街的剧院，黑人必须坐在楼上。他的父亲是一名律师，把镇上的邦联士兵雕像用作地标。
And he'd say, when you get on Main Street in Tazewell, find a Confederate soldier, and he's looking across the street, right in my office window. There was a pretty good, old Southern, Confederate flag, pickup truck culture back there. The word [BLEEP] was just used without even thinking. It was just no animosity, necessarily, but just a notion of they're them, and we's us, and we're probably inherently different. And it's a small town. You just didn't interact with them.
他说：“当你到了Tazewell的主街，找到那个邦联士兵，他正对着街对面，就在我办公室窗户里。”那里有相当不错的南方邦联卡车文化。那个N开头的词用起来根本不需要思考。那不一定是恶意，只是觉得“他们是他们，我们是我们，我们本质上大概就是不同的”。而且这是一个小镇。你就是不和他们互动。
Do you think that you were racist when you got to VES?
你认为你到VES时是种族主义者吗？
Probably. Probably. Not in an overt, hostile way, but I'm sure I had attitudes that would be fairly described as racist, sure.
大概吧。大概吧。不是那种公开、敌对的方式，但我肯定有会被相当准确地描述为种族主义的态度，当然。
Was Jerrauld your first Black friend?
Jerrauld是你第一个黑人朋友吗？
Oh, sure. Sure, absolutely.
噢，当然。当然，绝对是。
Jerrauld was another Stouffer scholar. John says that he and Jerrauld really got to know each other junior year. They were on the yearbook staff together, John working as a photographer, and Jerrauld as an editor. And they used to joke around about how different they were. John was a white country boy who was seldom without his .22 rifle, and Jerrauld was a Black kid from Norfolk, the big city, in John's eyes.
Jerrauld是另一位Stouffer学者。John说他和Jerrauld是在高二真正熟悉起来的。他们在年鉴编辑部工作，John做摄影师，Jerrauld做编辑。他们经常开玩笑说他们有多么不同。John是个白人乡下男孩，手里几乎总是拿着他的.22步枪，而在John眼里，Jerrauld是个来自大城市诺福克的黑人小伙子。
John went on to work as an engineer for the railroad. He had a lot of Black coworkers, and he says, outside of VES, it was his first daily close contact with Black people. And his experience at VES prepped him for that. He says he understood they were the same as him. He didn't interact much with his Black coworkers socially, but he says he became less racist over time.
John后来在铁路公司做工程师。他有很多黑人同事，他说，在VES之外，这是他第一次与黑人进行日常的近距离接触。他在VES的经历为他做好了准备。他说他明白他们和他是一样的。他在社交上与黑人同事没有太多互动，但他说随着时间推移，他变得不那么种族主义了。
There was no epiphany, where you smack your forehead and go, wow! It's more like watching it get dark at night. You can't really watch it happen as it happens, but it just ends up being dark. I guess that's the way learning is. You don't really realize it's happening until all of the sudden you realize, huh, there's a change in me.
没有那种灵光一现，让你拍着额头说“哇！”的时刻。这更像是看着天黑下来。你无法真正观察到它发生的过程，但最终它就是黑了。我想这就是学习的方式。你真的没意识到它正在发生，直到突然间你意识到，“嗯，我身上发生了变化”。
It's a really lovely thought, I just kind of wish he'd used a sunrise metaphor instead.
这真是一个可爱的想法，我只是有点希望他能用一个日出的比喻。
At the reunion, John heard that Jerrauld and the other Black students were put into his school partly for his benefit, to change his thinking. I told him how a couple got beat up. They faced racial slurs. Was it fair to put that on them?
在重聚上，John听说Jerrauld和其他黑人学生被送进他的学校部分是为了他的利益，为了改变他的想法。我告诉他其中几个人被打了，他们面临种族蔑称。把这强加给他们公平吗？
I'm sorry it happened. I never realized the racial crap that they put up with. I think it's a fair question, what you're asking, but I don't see a way around it. There is no way you're going to take young, southern, white males of privilege and educate them in diverse ways without exposing them to Black students. And you're going to be asking a lot of the Blacks what you're going to put in that situation.
我很抱歉发生了这样的事。我从没意识到他们忍受的那些种族烂事。我认为你问的是一个公平的问题，但我没看到有别的方法。没有办法可以在不接触黑人学生的情况下，以多元的方式教育年轻的南方白人特权男性。而且你要把黑人放在那种情况下，你确实是对他们要求很高。
He said he thought about Jerrauld for years when they weren't in touch. He'd see things on the news, especially things going on in the country, like Charlottesville, and think about Jerrauld and wonder what he thought. He wanted to hear his opinion.
他说他多年来一直想着Jerrauld，尽管他们没有联系。他会在新闻里看到一些事情，特别是国内发生的事情，比如夏洛茨维尔骚乱，然后就会想到Jerrauld，想知道他怎么看。他想听听他的意见。
I ran that by Jerrauld. It was a surprise to him. I believe John when he tells me his experience with Jerrauld changed him. By the time he had two high school-aged daughters, he could point to what that change meant.
我把这个告诉了Jerrauld。这对他来说是个惊喜。我相信John告诉我他与Jerrauld的经历改变了他。当他有两个上高中的女儿时，他能指出那种改变意味着什么。
I can recall coming in after work or something, and maybe it'd be 8 o'clock at night and there'd be a half a dozen kids up here with pizzas from Little Caesar's, and there might be two Black guys in there. My attitude when I was growing up would have been, what are they doing here? As opposed to, instead, now, it's just like, hey, look who's here. It's just a bunch of kids here. I knew them and I liked them, and I was glad to have them in the house. And without VES, I probably wouldn't have that attitude. And I actually was aware of that, looking at it and sort of thinking, damn, John, you've come a ways since you were a young man.
我记得下班回来，也许是晚上8点，有半打孩子在这儿吃Little Caesar's的披萨，其中可能有两三个黑人小伙子。我成长过程中要是这种情况，态度会是：“他们在这里干什么？”相反，现在就是：“嘿，看谁在这儿。”这只是一堆孩子。我认识他们，我喜欢他们，我很高兴家里有他们。如果没有VES，我可能不会有那种态度。我实际上意识到了这一点，看着这一切，心里想：该死，John，你和你年轻的时候比，真的进步了不少。
When Anne Forsyth started this experiment in the '60s, her vision was way grander than this. She was picturing future titans of industry, governors and senators whose prejudice would be melted away. And she launched this idealistic project not really knowing what she was doing, but taking her best shot. I think she never would have pictured this as one of the results-- a middle-aged white man stumbling onto a pizza party and thinking everything was all right, and in a sense, looking back over years that he wasn't all right before. It's so modest, but it's something.
Anne Forsyth在60年代开始这个实验时，她的愿景比这宏大得多。她设想的是未来的工业巨头、州长和参议员，他们的偏见将被消融。她发起了这个理想主义的项目，并没有真正知道自己在做什么，但全力以赴。我想她永远不会把这想象成结果之一——一个中年白人撞见一个披萨派对，觉得一切都很好，而且从某种意义上说，回首往事，他曾经并不好。这太谦虚了，但这确实是某种成果。
Mosi Secret. He's an Eric and Wendy Schmidt fellow at New America. He's working on a book about the Stouffer experiment. At our website this week, you can see pictures of Bill and Marvin as freshmen and seniors and read part of their applications. That's thisamericanlife.org.
Mosi Secret。他是新美国组织（New America）的Eric and Wendy Schmidt研究员。他正在写一本关于Stouffer实验的书。本周在我们的网站上，你可以看到Bill和Marvin作为新生和大四学生的照片，并阅读他们申请书的部分内容。网址是 thisamericanlife.org。
Our program was produced today by Susan Burton. Our staff includes Elise Bergerson, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Mariya Karimjee, Jonathan Menjivar, BA Parker, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lily Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed.
今天的节目由Susan Burton制作。我们的工作人员包括Elise Bergerson, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Mariya Karimjee, Jonathan Menjivar, BA Parker, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lily Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, 和 Diane Wu。我们的高级制作人是Brian Reed。
Research help from Michelle Harris. Music help from Damien Graef.
研究帮助来自Michelle Harris。音乐帮助来自Damien Graef。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he went to a concert years ago and it really influenced his style of singing in the shower.
《美国生活》由公共广播交流电台（PRX）分发给各公共电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。你知道吗，他多年前去听了一场演唱会，那真的影响了他洗澡时的歌唱风格。
So even now, I sound a lot like a 13-year-old Hilary Duff.
所以即使现在，我听起来还很像13岁的Hilary Duff。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带来更多《美国生活》的故事。